[Music]  on Wednesday celebs worked it out on the  red carpet at the 2018 Brit Awards in  London Rita Ora dazzled in this  strapless white feathered ball gown I  could have really liked you  while Ellie Goulding was red hot in this  short long-sleeved plunging dress dual  Aoife turned heads in a pale pink  ruffled mini dress with a long fluffy  Train Camilla Kibeho donned this  stunning powder blue gown hailey Baldwin  slayed in a black and blue floor-length  number and Emma Bunton kept it sexy in  this black leather trench coat  [Music]  ed sheeran looked perfect and dapper in  this navy suit meanwhile Liam Payne and  Cheryl were couple goals liam in a gray  suit jacket and Cheryl in a little black  dress with black heels Millie Bobby  Brown looked adorable in a white dress  with black polka dots damn you  and Sam Smith kept it fresh in this teal  jacket with a burnt orange button down  I'm Way too good